is it okay to just wait till they're 18
to say hey when you're 18 you can buy
your own smartphone or is there an
intentional aspect of giving your kid a
smartphone before then
assess their own kids individually I'll
say this your kid will not get into a
worse College get a worse job or be
worse in life if you wait until age 18.
so your question on is it okay to wait
it's absolutely okay to wait because you
know what there isn't any science to
support there is zero science saying
that waiting to weight will harm
children when we say we use the hashtag
delay is the way delay is is the way is
a slow tech strategy it's not a no-tech
strategy kids are not resilient they're
just extremely adaptive and they roll
with things and they hide their traumas
resilience is a muscle that is taught
that is practiced that is flexed I
absolutely want us to develop resilience
in our children but did you hear what I
said develop resilience yeah yeah our
kids aren't naturally born resilient
they are born fragile and fabulous I
want my kids to know how to behave and
to respond to certain digital spaces to
know what to do if they see
so it's not a bubble wrap approach to
technology right I'm not telling
everybody to just cut all the chords and
move to a you know some sort of commune
and get rid of all of it I'm just simply
saying slow tech and not no Tech right
kid right Tech right time
[Music]
that was Chris McKenna father of four
four founder of protect young eyes an
organization helping families create
internet safe homes that are free from
porn predators and problems that protect
young eyes team performs hundreds of
presentations at schools churches and
non-profits a year and Crystal serves as
a technical expert to some of the
world's largest tech companies for
Chris's parental control knowledge and
experience his 2019 U.S Senate Judiciary
Committee testimony is an ongoing
Catalyst for federal and state online
child protection laws and earned protect
young eyes with dignity defense alert
award in 2020. in this conversation we
unpack the dangers of kids getting their
own smartphone and social media too
young age-appropriate technology how to
keep kids safe while accessing the
internet how to speak to our children
about porn screen addiction and problems
that come with tech use and keep open
and honest communication the best tips
for screen use rules and families the
rise in online sex extortion what
childhood was like for us versus what
it's become now and more you do not want
to miss the important information shared
in today's episode so without further to
do let's get started alright Chris thank
you so much for being here I cannot wait
for this conversation because I've been
wanting to talk about this topic of the
dangers of kids getting on technology
smartphones social media too young for a
really long time and I'm so glad I came
across you and your organization protect
young eyes so let's just jump right in
thanks for being here yeah my pleasure
I'm excited too Ellen can't wait so it
feels like a lot of people a lot of
parents know that they should wait to
give their kids smartphones and social
media but there's this temptation to
give kids phones early and then you just
kind of end up caving it it's becoming
more prevalent than ever so I wonder if
you could just kind of explain why
there's such a tension there and why
people are starting to Kate parents and
more and more kids are getting
smartphones as young as like eight years
old that's right yeah and this is a hard
conversation there's a lot of tensions a
lot of complexities and every family is
different right even you and I could
share we have larger families but
they're different in a lot of ways and
so the first thing I want to start with
is there's going to be a lot of moms
dad's parents whoever who listen to this
none of what I'm about to say is
intended to make you feel shameful or
bad about decisions you've made
naturally some of you listening to this
are gonna hear things I say and go well
oh crud I've already given it to them
right and so whether you've said no slow
or go I want all of us to listen through
the lens of what can I learn from this
to create a bridge of digital trust
between me and my kids because whether
they have a device or not it's important
to start building digital trust with our
kids so I just wanted to preface the
conversation with that because it's
really easy to just go all fear and doom
and gloom with technology and I don't
want any parent especially a mom to hear
that and have that be the frame through
which she parents her kids with
technology so back to your original
question which is a really good one the
pressure is real and I'm a marketer so I
would simply say the marketing is
legitimately good when it comes to this
that many of us have pair as parents
have believed the lie that our kids will
somehow be left behind somehow be left
out somehow not be as productive won't
get into the best college won't have the
best friends or all of these things if
they don't have their technology and
that's due to a lot of really good
marketing because at the end of the day
when I talk to parents about these
things and the things that do give us
concern about technology Ellen most of
it is our fault
when we look at the things that
keep us up at night that we worry about
with our kids in technology a lot of
it's our fault because we have given
technologies that were never designed
for children in the first place these
were all designed for adults and then we
put children inside of them and then we
wonder why young people with young
brains make decisions like young people
inside of adult technology and then we
get upset like that's Madness it when
you step back and look at it you go wow
because at the end of the day
when you were 14 or I was 14 if we would
have had these devices if we would have
had Tick Tock we would be as addicted to
it as they are
I mean I actually find these apps to be
addictive as an adult even with our
brains being fully developed let alone a
young child where your brain is still
developing and you're really just not
sure who you are in the world I I mean I
go back to what I was like in junior
high and and even high school if not
especially high school but I think
definitely Junior High in high school if
I had access to those apps where you're
looking at and comparing yourself to
others and I I talk about this a lot on
my channel if anyone listens to my
channel a lot face filters I have such
an issue with face filters and I think
that it's hard for adults to even not
compare themselves to what they look
like in the mirror comparing to what
everyone else is looking like on a
screen with a face filter let alone
young kids and so that just goes back to
exactly what you're saying about about
their brain still developing young kids
using an adult app
that's right and there's a lot of
science to support this because
sometimes I think it can come across as
just a bunch of crazy weird fearful
parents who are like don't do this don't
do this and the science is starting to
catch up with the anecdotal right you
have children I have children we know a
lot of things anecdotally from life
experience we live in the lives of our
children we see how they're impacted by
certain things and as a result that
experience causes us to make certain
decisions none of us well I would hope
at least none of us listening to this
podcast want harm to come to our
children like there's a primal instinct
to protect your kids and so we don't
make these decisions out of well we want
our kids to fall into problems or
falling we just we simply don't know the
risks and part of what we do at protect
young eyes is we want to bridge that gap
between amazing families like those
listening to this and technologies that
honestly Ellen care nothing about the
safety and protection of our children
with information so we can make good
risk-based decisions about our kiddos
because the science is starting to catch
up to what our mom and dad guts have
been telling us for a long time right
the science around as you've referred to
brain development that teen and tween
brains have a high susceptibility to
rewards the prospect of a reward that
scientifically they've proven this at
UCLA they've put young children teens
and adults in a room have given them all
the same task and they give them the
promise of a reward be it money or candy
or something else and repeatedly teams
even more than adults are more efficient
and successful at completing the task
when given the prospect of a reward and
you even I think we actually sort of
digitally met each other through
childhood 2.0 the movie that a friend of
yours referenced and that's how you're
like hey I gotta connect with this Chris
McKenna guy and there's a scientist in
it that talks about young people have a
high sensitivity to rewards now why
that's important Alan is because when
you look at the very structure of social
media social media is built on a system
of dopamine Rewards that come from a
certain number of likes a certain number
of followers a certain number of views a
certain number of comments all of those
create an anticipation dopamine isn't I
got the reward dopamine is I might get
the reward and social media and the
structures in all of those apps are
brilliant at dangling that carrot of
digital credibility digital currency in
front of us and as you said you and I
have supposedly fully developed
prefrontal cortexes that are able to
maybe make better executive decisions
about what we should and shouldn't be
doing my gosh those young teen brains
just simply don't stand a chance because
that part of their brain simply isn't
plugged in yet combined with the reward
susceptibility and that's a toxic
combination in front of apps that were
meant to engage at a neurological
intoxicating model
quick little break for our sponsor open
going into it I wasn't sure what to
expect but wow this app is absolutely
stunning you guys it's a mindfulness app
with daily breath work and meditation
classes as well as unlimited access to
their yoga Pilates and hit classes too
which are amazing I've never been more
enticed to take classes like this than
with this particular app the warm
Aesthetics and sounds are so inviting
like a warm hug honestly I love how the
teacher speaks to you as they are doing
the movements along with you when I
click on a class I honestly just take a
deep breath and feel like I'm in the
right place and open is doing a breath
work and meditation challenge for the
entire month of January their challenge
is to do 31 classes in 31 days and the
best part is that it's free you get
unlimited access to open for the entire
month from January 1st to the 31st it
only takes 10 minutes a day to
experience the benefits I feel so
uplifted and Powerful ready to take on
my day after I take one of these classes
and what you'll get out of this
challenge is invaluable it sets you up
for healthy habits in 2023 keeps us
accountable and we can stay connected
with our friends and Community with
their live classes and you'll also be
entered to win an open in-person Retreat
which is incredible so join me in opens
free meditation and bathroom challenge
it's totally free for the entire month
of January so go to withopen.com Ellen
Fisher to sign up or click the link in
the show notes and you mentioned at the
beginning that parents feel concerned
that their kids going to feel left out
if they don't get the smartphone because
everybody else has it that's a real a
real thing that kids experience when
you're in high school junior high
maybe even elementary school if you
don't have the thing that everybody has
then you might feel left out so how
should people how should parents respond
when their kid comes to them and it's
like Mom all the kids have a smartphone
why can't I have one or can I get one
please and let's say they're quite young
and maybe just not ready for one
yeah so there's a couple of things
around this one that's real right I I've
had that conversation with a lot of
parents and especially when a lot of
things were locked down we were locked
down pretty tight here in Michigan right
over the you know 2020 and 2021 and so
there was this stronger temptation to
keep our kids connected with others to
give them Technologies ahead of schedule
right so I'm sensitive that sympathetic
to that and sometimes kids do feel like
the only ones I'm a big fan of pressing
into that conversationally and saying to
your kids there's a reason why we've
made this decision we don't just make it
and forget it we invite our kids into
the reason why we've made some of these
decisions because it's role playing like
this honey I agree with you that there
are some things you're going to be left
out of but do you know what you're also
going to be left out of
you're going to be left out of cyber
bullying you're going to be left out of
some of these
just Temptations or these picking
yourself apart because your picture
isn't quite as beautiful or filtered as
your friend's picture you're going to be
left out of when the time is right to
have this conversation about pornography
or other inappropriate photos just
showing up in your DMs and things honey
I hear you you will be left out of
things
but I intend to leave you out of things
that can do you harm and this isn't I
think a part of this conversation that
parents can have with kids is we're
really good at saying no but we're not
often good at showing our kids what the
path to yes looks like okay so what do
you mean by that I mean by that is no
for now but honey I'm going to look for
signs in you I'm going to look for
characteristics and traits in you that
prove to me that you are ready for what
is a super computer in your pocket
right this iPhone or whatever it might
be and so lay some of those
characteristics out lay some of those
mile markers or guide posts out to say
right from the very beginning no before
age 15. like just whatever your
non-negotiable is and I protect young
eyes we say we don't want smartphones or
social media before age 15 and there are
scientific reasons behind that that we
can unpack here in just a minute but
whatever the number is in your family be
very clear about it but show them what
that looks like to get there you know
what hon if you continue to make good
choices your grades are good you
continue to treat your brothers and
sisters and your mom and dad with
respect and whatever those sort of whole
child attributes are that you're going
to lay out in front of your son or
daughter that you need to see
consistently and persistently go okay
yeah then we can try this and this is
the age in which we'll do it but you
know what hon I'm going to continue to
keep looking for some of those things
and oh by the way when I decide to put
this device in your hand
it's still mine
but I'll let you borrow it when you're
14 or 15 because everything connected to
the internet in this house while you're
a minor is co-owned by this guy or Mom
or whoever it is because what kind of
parent would I be if I put this
insanely intelligent piece of equipment
in your hand and I didn't stay involved
much like a weapon or whatever it might
be it's because I love you that and so
I'm a big fan of saying all of these
things like what's on the path what does
the digital culture of your family look
like even once it's in their hands what
is the nature of that
relationship with the device once you
have it I'm a big fan of talking about
those things early and often so they
don't only know now the answer is no but
there's a path based on my behavior as a
child to yes and I know what that looks
like I'm not surprised by it awesome so
before we unpack a little bit more about
like the age-appropriateness of when
each family should give their kid a
smartphone or access to that type of
Technology can you just lay the
foundation for the dangers of giving a
child a smartphone too young
sure
um I have a number of friends who are in
counseling or in therapy right they work
with families they work with others and
there's this idea that is talked about
in the counseling Community especially
when it comes to abuse or other
exposures traumas that children
experience that when things happen
early meaning off schedule right we're
developmentally whether you believe in a
higher power or not developmentally
there are things that we experience in
life according to a schedule right where
maturity wise and developmentally we're
ready to experience certain things
I think one of the most
uh one of the things that isn't talked
about enough that is having a
significant impact especially our young
people is way too many young people are
being exposed to content conversations
and information way ahead of schedule
I mean we can clearly because it's black
and white right we don't show young
people pornography okay we know that
right we don't want our sons and
daughters exposed to complete strangers
on the other side of a screen right
these are easy things that we can agree
to but what isn't being talked about
often enough Ellen is what I call the
inverse maturity impact of technology
what I mean by that is technology
because it's an information and a
connection oriented tool
it exposes young people to things
they're not ready for therefore it's
accelerating maturity
right 10 year olds in 2022 are what 15
year olds were back in the 1990s when I
was growing up right there's an
acceleration of maturity because of what
they're being exposed to it's too much
too soon on the other end of that
spectrum because I deal with a lot of
adults and young adults who deal with
addictions with technology technology
gives adults and young adults a lot of
reasons to not be adults to not engage
with real relationships because they're
addicted to pornography or to not engage
with the real world because they can't
stop gaming or whatever it might be
therefore it's a decelerator of maturity
when it comes to the other side of the
age Spectrum so it's this crazy impact
that in my observations I've seen both
on the Young and on those on the other
side of it where those I see it all the
time now teens and college students
going you know what I'm just going to
take a break from this for a while just
read an article recently from a student
at Notre Dame who went to a flip phone
and he goes through all of these amazing
skills and things he's observing about
the world now that he plays a guitar and
all this stuff that he had just quit
doing because he was mindlessly
scrolling on his phone
and he was realizing the impact it was
having on him so those are some of the I
mean a whole nother podcast you and I
could probably have related to
pornography or some of the specific
topics in there those are clearly risks
right it used to be when I was growing
up you know I'm a Gen X guy I had to go
find porn it was a destination it lived
somewhere outside of my home or for some
it was in the home but you had to go
find it what we've done and you'll
remember this quote of mine from the
movie we've put little boxes of porn in
their pockets
and it actively searches for them it
targets them it shows up in the ads in
the four plus apps it shows up in
unintended searches because a young
child types in t sex instead of T-Rex in
a Google search or whatever it might be
right it is pursuing their hearts and
minds and that is a radically different
posture for some of this content than
what I grew up with where I had to go
find bad things and had to go look for
it
yeah and it was still prevalent back
then even before smartphones growing up
it's like yep that's just something that
young kids I think the average age is
like 11 or something and might be
younger now you probably know the answer
but growing up it was just something
that the you know boys especially but
sometimes girls would seek it out when
no one else was around it took a lot of
intentionality and even and then it took
it became very very addictive at a very
young age whereas now when it's just in
your pocket all day long
I can only imagine how much more
exponentially exaggerated that aspect is
so get maybe for someone listening who
might be like okay but what's the big
deal like porn's not that big a deal can
what are your thoughts on that for so
many things sure sure and you know for
anybody we've done a lot of writing and
research and create a lot of content
around this topic so please come to our
website and you can search in our blog I
promise if you type the word pornography
into the search on our website you're
not going to get anything explicit it'll
be all good and helpful content but in
particular for that issue one of the I
would say most disturbing aspects of
Early Childhood exposures to pornography
is
based on conversations I've had with
children's assessment centers all over
the country so all over the United
States and I'm sure there are people who
listen to this outside of the U.S but in
the U.S there are these children's
assessment centers cacs that work with
families who have either been the
victims of sexual abuse their children
have been sexually abused or they have a
child who has abused another minor they
work on both sides of that recovery
Spectrum
and I've interviewed them and they'll
tell me like over a year they'll say
Chris okay of the 100 cases that I have
worked on this year the number one
common denominator
among children who sexually abuse other
children is an early childhood exposure
to pornography
because what young kids see they feel
neurologically compelled to do
we know that anecdotally from watching
our children how they copy us with
sometimes embarrassing Precision the
things that we say and do they have
mirror neurons they cause them to copy
the world around them so that they learn
and grow
I was at a conference
um Ellen back in April a large
Conference of Educators and I had the
opportunity to do a keynote talk in
front of about 3 000 educators
and afterwards at my booth where I was
talking to some of the the teachers
there I'm not exaggerating in a
20-minute span I had two principals come
up and tell me the exact same thing
that they had both just expelled a
fourth grade boy for the exact same
tragic reason
and it's because both of those boys had
inappropriately touched their teachers
and when they dug into the home they
found out both of those boys and the
parents didn't know this until it became
a suspension issue at school and they
started digging into things at home they
discovered that both of these boys were
actively watching pornography at home
so do you think that that's what's
happening is that the majority of the
time when a parent is giving their kids
a smartphone that they just have no idea
what's going on behind the behind the
front lines when they're not around well
I say those things but I also say
most kids make good choices online right
I want to say that I want to keep that
idea of Hope and diminish as much fear
in this conversation as possible I talk
in terms of risks why because before I
got in to protect young eyes and started
this about seven years ago for 12 years
Ellen my job was a risk manager I did
this for large publicly traded companies
I would go in to assess their business
processes find the risks and fix them so
that they wouldn't lose money or lose
products in the warehouse whatever it
was so my whole mindset on the world
professionally and as a parent is I look
for opportunities to mitigate risk
around things I care about
it just so happens right now it's my
kids who I care about the most and so I
want every parent to hear me that it's
not that every time you hand your child
a tablet that they are going to be
actively looking at and impacted by
pornography but I'm telling you we live
at a time where the risk of that
happening has never been greater
therefore we have to take both
relational and Technical steps to
prevent as much of that as possible to
mitigate those risks
yep and then on top of it there's the
factor that's always been kind of
assumed or known that like when a young
person is addicted to porn that it
affects their relationships going
forward let's say they're not having
those extreme examples you just gave
about the principles
um but just affects their relationships
going forward on what they think sex is
supposed to be like what women are
supposed to be like
um yeah just that aspect well we know
developmentally right we've talked about
this that what you expose young brains
to one of the phrases that we use with
our parents is that for all of its
complexity the brain operates according
to a very simple principle
and that is whatever you feed your
precious brain is what it learns to love
especially before age 15. therefore you
do start to shape what is initially a
very plastic brain and I've talked to
young adults who Ellen in spite of their
best efforts and all of the controls and
walls in place they cannot
neurologically stop craving pornography
because it created such deep ruts in
their brain during this critical
developmental time and so it's now I'm
not trying to get into First Amendment
issues with adults I have that
conversation all the time because I work
a lot on legislation and things that's a
a separate topic but for children
right we treat minors and children
differently
and this is a space where right now
we're putting them in adult places and
we're expecting them to behave
differently and we don't do that
anywhere else we don't put children in
dangerous playgrounds created for adults
and then get mad at them for getting
hurt or using it like they shouldn't we
don't put young children on adult-sized
bicycles without helmets and send them
down a mountain in Hawaii and then get
upset when they fall off of their bike
we put children in physical places and
we give them experiences that are
tailored and crafted for children
and we just are not doing that with our
technology and that's what concerns me
is there ever a reason then to wait to
until they're 18. is there ever a hard
hard line basically is what I'm asking
like is it okay to just wait till
they're 18 to say hey when you're 18 you
can buy your own smartphone and we're
not going to have smartphones before
then or is there an intentional aspect
of giving your kid a smartphone before
then what are your thoughts on
like I'm guessing every family is
different right but but what what are
your general thoughts they're that's a
really good question and it all depends
on the kiddo I want families to like
assess their own kids individually
I'll say this your kid will not get into
a worse College get a worse job or be
worse in life if you wait until age 18.
the marketing is going to try to tell
you something differently but I have a
18 year old college student right I
heard I'm not gonna or I'll use a
pseudonym for Emma okay she wrote me a
letter
after graduating from high school last
year she's from Michigan here close to
where I live and she wrote me this long
email letter about how her parents saw
one of my presentations when she was in
Middle School and made decisions about
her technology and decided to prevent
her from getting a smartphone and social
media until certain ages and she didn't
have social media in high school and she
thanked me because of what it's done to
her life
and how she has this perspective on
relationships and now she's an advisor
on my board because I love her
perspective that she has is now a
freshman in college just her seeing the
world without it being tainted by social
media so your question on is it okay to
wait it's absolutely okay to wait
because you know what there isn't any
science to support there is zero science
saying that waiting to wait will harm
children
but on the other hand I think sometimes
parents believe the fear and I speak
into it is that if I don't let them
experience it now then they'll go off to
college and they'll experience it maybe
some of us had really sheltered children
you know childhoods and we went off to
college and we became just crazy and
wild because we didn't have any
restraints and we just tried everything
went to all the parties in the bars and
all that stuff and I think that more Gen
X and maybe older Millennial parent
mentality I don't think that quite
translates to this because I think what
waiting does and then they go to college
and they see their college friends stuck
scrolling on their phone for hours I
don't think there's a lot of them that
go man I wish I had that
man I wish that I was up all night
gaming and failed my chemistry test
like I just don't think that is an
Apples to Apples comparison even though
the fear in our brain might make us go
well we have to let them be exposed to
it now I want to put a little bit of a
caveat around that Ellen because when we
say and we use the hashtag delay is the
way delay is is the way is a slow tech
strategy it's not a no-tech strategy I
Am pro technology my 11 and 12 year old
boys love to play video games and you
know what I play with them I'm horrible
but I play with them
right and so I want them to be exposed
to certain digital spaces and I want
them to know with my guidance what to do
when they're in them because Ellen the
truth is I don't control them all when
Cole goes to Ty's house or Blake goes to
a friend's house I want my kids to know
how to behave and to respond to certain
digital spaces to know what to do if
they see something so it's not a bubble
wrap approach to technology right I'm
not telling everybody to just cut all
the chords and move to a you know some
sort of commune and get rid of all of it
I'm just simply saying slow tech and not
no Tech right kid right Tech right time
we educate them so they know what to do
one of the phrases we say that goes like
this it's even if you've said no teach
your kids about technology as if you've
said yes
because I still want them to understand
how to navigate it even if it's not
theirs if that makes sense
right so how do you have that
conversation with your child and at what
age should you be having these
conversations with your child about
pornography or things they may come
across when they're using a screen I
want every single parent who listens to
this podcast or watches this video
I want you to make a list of all of the
horrible things that you hope your child
never experiences online
and then over the next month I want you
to find an age-appropriate way to talk
to your children about all of them
because I believe there is an
age-appropriate way to have all of those
conversations we have a post on our blog
and you find it in Instagram or any
other you know the social media places
we are that's called how to talk to a
five-year-old about pornography and it
goes through scenarios right and if you
it's really good and if you read that
I would ask you know someone who reads
that to get to the end of it and I would
ask them this question in that exchange
that I went through with my son Blake
when he was five did I ever use the word
pornography once and the answer is no
but did Blake know exactly what to do if
he saw pornography as you and I would
Define it and the answer is absolutely
yes
now I think that
very young kids are ready for these
conversations it's a lot of our own
baggage and our own fear that we often
bring into these conversations that
really isn't their reality we almost
impart our fears and we impart our
awkwardness on them our kids are often
ready and we give them digital
confidence
instead of curiosity when we give them
some of these words and phrases
one of the things you've heard me say
you know in out of context it really
freaks parents out sometimes is I want
porn to be the norm in other words it's
a normal conversation it's a word that
doesn't evoke curiosity it evokes
conversation in our kids because they
know that Mom is trust mom has talked
about this forever if I ever have a
question I want I just you know say this
too I want kids to Google us because
we're the authority we're the ones
they've listened to we're the ones that
they know is going to give us a straight
answer and we invite them to do that as
often impossible as possible and it's
not just that it's anything they might
experience online anything that makes
them feel uncomfortable I tend to widen
the words around that that it's not just
you know if you see somebody who doesn't
have their clothes on or under the
bathing suit or naked people that's it's
honey if you ever get that little funny
feeling in your belly and you know what
I'm talking about that little radar that
tells you something's not quite right
I want you to listen to that your
feelings are a superpower I want you to
listen to that and whenever you feel
that I want you to do a couple of things
I want you to put it down I want you to
tell someone whether it's something you
see something somebody shows you you
will never be in trouble by bringing
that feeling to me
and I want you to listen to that and do
that and you practice that phrase you
say that to your kids over and over and
over again so that it's automatic
that is a really great way to phrase
that because I think a lot of times
parents just don't know how to approach
those types of conversations and they're
just afraid to be like if I bring it up
maybe it's gonna stroke that Curiosity
more but really when you just present
the information in the way that you're
explaining it it's having a beautiful
conversation where they know if they
come and see something like this I
should go talk to Mom and Dad because
that's really how it starts they come
across something maybe no one told them
that this is something that can even be
on their screen and it's it gives them
that feeling and then they go back to it
over and over again in secrecy and shame
without ever telling anybody about it
that's right and that's the relational
side but you said something and that is
there is the Curiosity side that I do
want again my risk mitigation head on I
do want to handle it from both sides so
when you have these conversations there
are some children that will have a lot
of questions and initially they're not
going to be comfortable asking you all
of those questions but that's where the
technical side comes in to mitigate some
of that Curiosity that's why we have a
router in our house that controls the
Wi-Fi that doesn't per you know doesn't
allow anything pornographic or explicit
or problematic to get into the house in
the first place that we keep devices out
of bedrooms that we have certain filters
and controls on things and this is the
sort of the beautiful Union then between
the relational conversations to create
that digital trust with your kids but
then the technical side to take care of
all that other kind of lingering risk
that is out there and the combination of
those two things is often enough to sort
of build those layers we we have
multiple layers of protection that we
teach on when it comes to protecting and
preparing our children so
and where can people learn how to turn
on those filters and do all those steps
that you're saying to keep the house
safe sure so if you come to protectyoung
eyes.com in the menu there's a few
choices blog apps and you'll see under
parental controls devices and Ellen
there's a whole page device by device
whether it's Alexa or the Chromebook or
the new VR goggles that you've maybe
given your kid under the tree
um or for their birthday or whatever it
happens to be
all of those step-by-step guides for how
to control if controls are possible are
there on the website we also built an
app that can be found in the App Store
that have very swipeable little panels
of information to set these sort of
things up we just want it to be as easy
as possible because I'm not a tech
person Ellen I know that's going to
shock some people and that's not a very
credible thing to say as like the head
of an Internet safety organization but
I'm a CPA who went into Ministry who
watched middle school kids from 2009 to
2016 start to carry the internet with
them and it was that consultant's you
know problem-solving brain that I said
this is a problem and it needs a
solution so I created protect young eyes
and have done the thousands and
thousands of hours of research now to
understand it better and that's what
parents will find at our website because
I think all of us you know even if you
don't have any tech knowledge all of us
have what I call digital parenting
superpowers you just need a little boost
to unleash them and we want to be able
to do that for you
so is there a way to give your kid a
smartphone
in a safe way that protects them then if
you're like toggle off all the abilities
to come across information or download
apps or whatever what about that aspect
that a parent says well I have all the
safety controls turned on and I like
them having a smartphone so I know where
they are at all times what's your
thoughts on that well I think there are
ways to stay in touch with our kiddos
that don't require them to carry the
internet with them
okay so what are those ways so there's a
difference between devices that have
been created for children and
smartphones so when I refer to a
smartphone I'm referring to let's say an
iPhone or an Android device there are
other devices that allow us to
communicate with our children like the
new bark phone or gab or pinwheel or
other child friendly devices that people
can find described you know again on our
website we've blogged about these we've
tested all them I have them all here in
my office you know to actually run them
through the ringer my own children have
used some of them but these are devices
actually designed for kids where I can
see where my child is at through GPS on
the watch that Cole is wearing as he
rides his bike to the speedway to get a
slushie right that kind of stuff I can
call him I can control his contacts but
he doesn't have games he doesn't have
social media he doesn't have internet
and he doesn't need those things when
he's out and about with his friends but
you better believe as a you know let's
be honest recovering helicopter parent
of 2022 I I still want to know where my
kiddo is you know those sorts of things
yes and that's important today and I
understand that I just again it's not no
Tech it's slow tech right Tech at the
right time and I think that's the way to
do that
so is there a way then on like an actual
smartphone to just toggle off those
abilities to have access to the internet
or apps like for some reason I think
that's a common theme and question
people have like can I just get my kid a
smartphone and just make it safe yeah
definitely there are ways to do that and
you would find all of those instructions
on our website and I'll say that no
matter how many toggles and switches you
toggle off there are always going to be
back back doors and that's where the
combination is important don't rely
solely on the toggles and the technical
to solve preparing your children for
digital if you're going to give your kid
a smartphone it's you know I'm going to
toggle a few things off why because I'd
be a really horrible parent if I didn't
and I love the heck out of you and so
I'm going to give you this device and I
know I'm role-playing for a minute here
right I know honey that there's probably
17 or 18 back doors that are in Tick
Tock videos that you can find on this
device I'm about to give you
but you know what
you're not going to do that
because I need some trust here I need to
know that I can trust you with this and
you can choose to use it well and if you
do I'm going to let you keep using it
but if you don't I'm going to pull it
back and that's where put all of those
things that they could do out in front
of them because in my experience when
you do that they automatically have less
pull less control over our kids because
they kind of go oh yeah
mom knows what I'm up to all right I'm
just going to make better choices I
think it's just that's the relational
side of the technical weaknesses that
exist on these devices
right yeah because I have a friend who
who's older oldest daughter is I think
she's 17 or 16. um but she's like a very
mature 16 or 17 year old and she likes
her smart she that she gave her a
smartphone so that she can download all
of her
um her books because she likes to listen
to books and then she also has it for
when she goes to her job and so it does
make sense how it just really depends on
each kid and like you said about
um watching their development being
aware of it having conversations with
them so before uh we touched on um porn
a little bit can we talk about social
media can you talk about the dangers of
kids having their own Instagram Tick
Tock YouTube because one of my first
um experiences of a young kid having
social media was when my first child
who's 11 now but he was about two years
old or maybe three and we were outside
hanging with the kids in the
neighborhood and one of the neighborhood
kids came up he was about seven or eight
and he had his own smartphone and I was
just so blown away because like I didn't
get a smartphone until I was 21 like
other people had smartphones and I just
waited and delayed you know I was just
trying to save money and I just thought
I don't need one I could just have a
flip phone finally when I got it at 21 I
I got it and I'm like dang this is an
addicting app like you just it's so
addicting to just scroll and get on it
and be on it and as an adult so when I
saw a seven and eight year old
having his own app or his own smartphone
I was really blown away and I saw how
quickly he would pull out his phone pull
up YouTube have on some rap video with
like rap
um a rap music video quite inappropriate
and all the kids will head it around and
they're all watching it no supervision
I'm just standing here with my
three-year-old like wait what's going on
right now what do we do so yeah let's
talk about social media yeah and um
I'll just make the broad statement that
I don't think brains that are not at
least 15 years old are ready for those
pressures Ellen you described what it
was like as a 21 year old I didn't
acquire social media till I was in my
30s
I know from running a business through
social media how ridiculously difficult
it is for me to put it down and how easy
it is for me just to scroll
it's designed to do that so I would
simply say to parents listen social
media doesn't care about your kid
in fact social media wants to consume as
much time and conscious attention of
your child
okay it's not going to turn every child
into somebody who is depressed it's not
going to cause every child who has
social media to want to take their life
it's not going to cause them to be Cyber
Bullied automatically again I'm just
saying that the science is starting to
point to the fact
that all of those things have a greater
probability of happening for young
people who have early exposures to
social media
the science has started to support that
so again sometimes that makes me sound
like a super conservative parent but
again I go through the lens of risk
mitigation why would I put my child in a
spot that creates a disproportionate
amount of risk for their life
I call it a digital soup right in
Michigan because you know we're cold at
least half of the Year here we get in in
September we get into soup season okay
we joke about that in Michigan so we
love a good soup and when you make a
good soup Ellen you know a good marinade
or whatever it might be with meats and
vegetables and spices whatever it is
right in a lot of different cultures
have good soups you never quite know how
it's exactly going to taste because all
the different things you put in there
pick up different herbs and spices why
because the meat and the vegetables have
different nooks and crannies and
crevices right all a little bit
different and I think the same thing is
true when it comes to our children and
social media right we drop our children
into digital soup
now their nooks and crannies and
crevices are their experiences traumas
nature and nurture all these things that
a human being brings into life right the
way that we parent them the things that
happen to them the way that they are
genetically all of these things
each and every child who gets dropped
into that digital soup because of the
complicated combination of their nature
and nurture and experiences is going to
come out of that soup impacted different
ways
therefore it's so complex I don't know
what is going to happen to every child
which makes me go why in the world would
I drop them in there in the first place
right it's not a formula I can't say
okay if you have a child and you put
them in Instagram this is exactly what's
going to happen it'd be a lot easier to
parent if it was that sequential or that
linear but it simply isn't and so I've
looked at the science and I've looked at
the evidence and I've looked at tens of
thousands of conversations with parents
literally all over the world and I don't
just say that to sound hyperbolic like I
literally did a parent presentation at
the German Embassy in Tehran Iran last
summer and those parents had the exact
same questions we do Ellen the exact
same concerns
and that is why would we continue to
drop our young people into this digital
soup that we know so little about to me
that's just simply a risk I'm not
willing to take any sooner than I need
to
absolutely I mean I just think I keep
going back to what it was like being in
junior high in high school and how you
know the most that we had in regards to
technology and relations and bullying
and stuff like that was there was this
website called hotornot.com hell yeah
yeah and it was like the big honking
computer and computer class we would go
in and like look at the pictures and you
put your picture up and that was like
the talk of the thing of the whole group
right but now it's like everyone has
their smartphones they're trading
pictures there's bullying involved one
of my young friends who's in high school
here in Hawaii when I asked her like
what's it like at school right now does
everybody have a smartphone she's like
yeah everyone pretty much everyone has a
smartphone sure yeah and she said if you
don't have a smartphone you're not cool
and then and then there's experiences
where you know
um girls are having videos taken of them
when they're with a boyfriend and they
don't know and then it gets shared with
their friends and it's shared with
everyone at school and just the exchange
of that of everybody having access to
that type of thing is so scary to me
because I think about how insecure I was
in in those times of Junior High in high
school I can't even imagine what it
would be like if I was constantly
comparing myself to all these you know
beautiful women on social media with
face filters and not in like fully
edited images that's not who they really
look like so yeah to me that even more
so the aspect of potentially connecting
with an online Predator I think about
just the insecurity factor and what
happens relationally yeah yeah I call
that the whisper of Instagram right you
and I and I don't think men are immune
to this either there are Whispers that
social media is constantly chattering
behind us right and I think what most
often happens in in women or in young
adults who are women because I've done a
lot of work in Ministry with you know
with both guys and girls is that
comparison is so toxic and I think that
happens more often in young ladies than
a dozen guys again we're not immune but
I'm just saying that social media wants
that why because if it can pull you into
that comparison game
it's a zero sum there's no winning to
that right because it pulls you down
that rabbit hole of more and more and
more and so you're right that can be
toxic if I could just I
I want to just tell like a 60-second
story so there's a school here in the
town that I live in in Grand Rapids here
and
four years ago about they decided to
remove during the day all smartphones
K-12 in other words you can't have them
out during the day right it's an away
for the day policy and this is not like
some small Rinky Dink school this is
division one 19 000 students or whatever
19 buildings across ten thousands it's a
huge School District okay
and the superintendent who's a a
gentleman that I've sat down and talked
with multiple times Ellen
he has regular meetings with students he
calls them soup with the super you know
and he sits down and the cafeteria and
has lunch with some of the kids and he
was asking him about this new policy
right what do you guys think it was uh
eighth grade group that he was sitting
down with and there was an eighth grade
girl who said
uh Mr Beam I enjoy coming to school now
and he's like tell me more about that
like what do you mean by that and she
said and I'll paraphrase a little bit
the full story is in the blog post on
our website
what she told him was when I was in
seventh grade every morning I would
spend at least an hour getting ready
because I never knew during the day when
somebody might take my picture
and I was so afraid that I wouldn't look
good in that picture that was going to
be posted online that I had to look good
and it was this anxiety I had all day
long and she said now I can be me hmm
well that's the thing like I I get teary
every time I I say it because I just
have such a love for the the hearts of
young people to be their authentic
selves and how social media just
radically wants them to be something
other than their authentic selves it
wants to craft them into an algorithmic
version of fakeness and things that I
hear a story like that and I just man
that's what it's all about right I want
to preserve that beauty and that
innocence that children have as long as
possible and that's just not what social
media is designed to do yeah and when I
was talking to my young friend who's
here in high school I was bringing up
the concept of like have you ever
considered the concept of like not
having a smartphone or like what about
face filters what are your thoughts on
face filters and they're like oh
whatever I'm like but do you see the
harm in it like it makes you look
different than what you actually look
like and then you look in the mirror do
you feel insecure when you don't have
that face filter on and they're like
actually yeah I'm like what what could
we do here like how can we how can we
prevent event this because I don't know
if we're gonna just look back and think
wow I can't believe we did that crazy
social experiment or if we're gonna just
keep going in this trajectory and this
this direction and US oldies are going
to talk about back in the good old days
when there was no social media in high
school and you're gonna they're gonna
get looked at like you're crazy so I
like I was asking my friend like I got I
was asking my friend well what if you
guys tried to make it cool to not have a
smartphone like what if you guys just
got together and was like because they
really liked this idea when I was
unpacking like you know growing up we
didn't have a smartphone and I'm talking
about this this idea and they're like
wow actually that would be really cool
because of all the there's so much
sadness and frustration that happens
with it in high school they're telling
me these stories I'm like can you get
together can you just be like we don't
need a smartphone and that's what's cool
because sometimes doing the different
thing is what's cool I'm like is what is
there a case for that or is there a case
for what you said this example of a
whole school shutting down Smartphones
at school and like is there something
like in let like legislatively that we
could do or what are your thoughts on
what work do you want to see happen with
young kids on social media
well there are layers here right so
there's the there's the child layer the
parent layer the
um
we'll call it the the school layer the
legislative layer and then the company
layer right these are the four layers so
when I say company I'm talking like
Google Apple and the others think of it
like a triangle at the very bottom of
that triangle in other words those who
have the most control over these
experiences are the companies they built
the Technologies and they could do far
more than what they're doing but
unfortunately what's happened Ellen is
most of the responsibility has been
placed on the smallest part of the
triangle and that is parents and kids to
figure this out
so I say that in that in a perfect world
we would have
a higher level of corporate and
legislative responsibility
but we don't live in that world I think
we're hopefully trending in that
direction and we work a lot in that way
but until we get there right we're in
the middle of this what I call sort of
big tobacco moment right I'm watching
some documentaries right now and some
shows with my wife on Netflix and one of
them is staged back in the 1920s and I'm
telling you like everybody is smoking
like packs and packs a day right and
we're in that phase now until we get to
a spot where maybe we have more science
to back up some of these choices that
you and I in our gut feel like are the
right ones I love it when kids get
together and make some of those choices
when it's their idea in fact anybody
listening to this I would invite you to
Google the ludic club Luddite Club
that's it l-u-d-d-i-t-e and this is
group Luddite in New York City of these
17 in the New York Times just profiled
them they got together and they have all
not all all but most decided to get flip
phones and it's all about removing
social media from their life and the
stories they talk about about their
brains waking up about how one has like
noticed graffiti now on the way to
school and the beauty of Art and now
reads books and like the stories that
these 16 and 17 year olds are telling
now that they've joined the club
about what they see in the world about
how they feel are so rich and good
so can kids do these things do they have
the power and the you know awesomeness
to do this absolutely and it's always
better when it's their idea because then
it's not a bunch of adults shaking their
finger at them going you should take
your phone away like when a 17 year old
wakes up and goes you know what I don't
like how I am with this and that's what
one of them did and she put it in a box
and she saw her life just explode with
goodness
right that's the stuff that fires me up
yes totally totally that's amazing that
would be so cool if we could see some
kind of movement of that though so that
would be super awesome so something
that's really common that people say is
kids are resilient what are your
thoughts on that that you know this is
just the times now children are
resilient it's a concept that like I I
think that it's like escape and escape
to be held accountable for maybe giving
your kids a smartphone at a really young
age but what are your thoughts
so I would ask everybody who's listening
or watching this to answer a couple of
questions for me
first I would say okay how many of you
have heard the phrase kids are resilient
and most people would probably raise
their hands and then I would ask them
this this is exactly what I do in my
talks with parents Ellen I say how many
of you have ever seen the show Criminal
Minds
and most people raise their hands and
then I say okay let me summarize 17
seasons of Criminal Minds for you the
behavioral analysis unit gets some
report of some horrible killings that
are happening in a small town they get
in their private jet they show up in a
small town and there's always one police
officer here she always has a cowboy hat
for some reason they go out to some
Farmhouse out in the building somewhere
or some weapons or tools that are always
planking in the wind then they come back
inside of the house and on the mantle in
the house is a cracked glass photo that
is the childhood of the person that
they're pursuing
and then we find out some story of
trauma neglect or abuse that happened in
the life of this person and then they
chase the person through the woods happy
episodes they kill them half the
episodes they don't that's 17 seasons of
Criminal Minds and what is common in 99
of them is Early Childhood trauma
make no mistake children are not
resilient
Ellen if you and I were to lay down you
know respectively at a couch with a
therapist and unpack Our Lives the way
that we see ourselves we look in the
mirror the Little voices that we meddle
with that medal with us in our heads the
way that we treat our spouses our
relationships if we really unpack all of
those things and how you and I are today
as adults I guarantee most of that came
from ages 5 to 15. yeah the way that we
are today right we look at both our
awesomeness and our flaws and our
traumas those things do not die easily
now can we recover and come through it
absolutely but it takes a ridiculous
amount of effort kids are not resilient
they're just extremely adaptive and they
roll with things and they hide their
traumas and they move forward and they
put a smile on and they keep playing but
underneath they are wounded and hurt and
it'll show up later
so make no mistake children are not
resilient and I love having that
conversation just seeing the light bulbs
go on with people and they go oh my gosh
when I look in the mirror you are
absolutely right
it totally has to do with the
experiences we had growing up and how we
are today so resilient is like yes kids
bounce back yes they they can go with
the flow they roll with the punches type
thing but like how does it affect them
growing into their life is the bigger
question that's right yeah I think we
think we think resilience is inherent in
other words children just have it
resilience is a muscle that is taught
that is practiced that is flexed I
absolutely want us to develop resilience
in our children but did you hear what I
said develop resilience yes yeah our
kids aren't naturally born resilient
they are born fragile and Fabulous
therefore we teach them resilience
through giving them opportunities to
explore the world and sometimes skin
their knees and sometimes explore a
little too far within our loving bounds
and figure out oh that hurt me or that
did that okay what do we learn from that
all right that is building that muscle
of relational emotional physical
resilience that of course I want our
kids to have I don't want to Bubble Wrap
our children from the world to create a
bunch of weak adults who don't know how
to deal with the difficultness of being
an adult right so that's where I think
resilience to your point gives us
excuses for lazy choices with our
children
and instead I want the concept of
resilience to prompt us to action show
our kids how to use technology and good
and positive ways because we've
developed that inside of them dropping a
smartphone in their lap at age eight is
not a good idea because we think they're
resilient they're not yep and you said
show them how to use the smartphone it
makes me think of being the example and
how easy it is for parents to be on
their smartphone all the time so that's
some another aspect that's really
important to what we're showing our kids
if they're walking up to us are we
putting down the screen that we're
looking at and get looking them directly
in the eye or are we so hooked to our
screens that we're like uh-huh hold on
hold on hold on hold on I'm looking at
something that is really important part
an important part of the conversation as
well I think absolutely yeah one of the
talks that we give is what we call the
digital culture of kids and it goes
through our framework so we have a
digital trust framework that is copy me
Coldplay curiosity conversation and
coaching those five words words the
first one is copy me and it's
intentionally the first one because I
have to ask myself pretty frequently
would I want my daughter and my sons to
use their technology just like Dad where
I use it how I use it and what I use it
for
right if I've told my kids they can't
have their phone in their bedroom then I
need to find something other than Candy
Crush or fantasy football to go to bed
with right I can't listen to music
before I go to bed I need to find an old
school alarm clock right I need to lead
the way if I've said to my kids hey
there's a filter that needs to go on
your phone
and parents will fight me on this but
I'll tell you one of the most amazing
ways to lead your children is to say you
know what whether you're 4 14 or 40 a
filter is probably a good idea because
there's stuff that Dad doesn't need to
see either
I know I'm an adult and I have the
constitutional right to look at whatever
I want I get all that stuff but our kids
don't
and I think it's important to lead the
way with some of those choices here
absolutely right yeah being the example
of how addicted are you to your
smartphone because even if you say all
right I'm not going to get my my kid a
phone a smartphone until they're 17 or
18 or 16 or whatever it is
um how they're watching us they're
watching you how you handle a smartphone
and the moment they do get one they're
gonna start using it the way that you
use it so you like you said I love that
question do you want your kid to be
using your their phone the way that
you're using a phone I love that because
for me I have like a real strict policy
that like I am not on my phone during
the day unless I'm answering an
important text or maybe answering a
phone call from my sister or my mom
um
unless it's work time and if I'm working
I'm like this is workspace mom knows
she's working and that's like a CO like
because my kids know that like my work
is online and so it's very different
than like scrolling while I'm like you
know to me it's like I don't like to
scroll while I'm eating I want to be
present look at my kids talk to them
while I'm eating
um all of that aspect like don't be on
and off on and off throughout the day
when I'm homeschooling the kids for me
it's like it's gone I'm just
homeschooling the kids and we're
together so yeah that's amazing and you
know I think we each need to just take a
real honest look in the mirror when it
comes to that that's why copy me is the
first part of the digital trust
framework because it starts with us
you know Ellen I've just come to believe
that most of what I do other than very
intentional testing right that I have to
do for protect young eyes because we
dive into all the places we don't want
our kids to so that parents know the
risks but for the most part I should be
able to show what's on my phone to a 12
year old
I mean that's why my daughter Andrea and
I we all share the same six digit
passcode for our iPhone right no secrets
my boys so Cole and Blake they both know
the six digit code for my iPhone and if
they want to use it like hey Dad can I
watch something quick I got some video I
want to watch about some speed run
through this game okay cool yep well
here's my phone and they type it in they
have to ask permission but they know it
why because I want them to know that
there's nothing dad needs to hide on
this thing that's a powerful example to
them about the devices that they use
that there's nothing they need to hide
on that device either
so try to lead the way
yeah do you feel like that's different
for older kids versus younger kids
because of the ability to have
self-control maybe when they're younger
like five six seven or even eight at
that point do you feel like it's
different to where it's like you don't
want them to have the ability to open
the phone because that's another level
of safety where they could get into
something accidentally yeah definitely
right so there's an inverse relationship
there that we lean more on control the
younger they are and we lean more on
relationship the older they are right so
there's a balance there between that
Technical and relational right I don't
want to talk to a six-year-old after
they've seen pornography I just don't
want them to see it therefore I'm going
to block and do as much technically as I
can to filter that stuff out now when a
child's a little bit older like I'll use
my daughter as an example I didn't check
her phone very much at all like as she
was an older teenager we had certain
controls in place and when she couldn't
couldn't use it and she knew that I
could because I always knew her passcode
but for the most part I was like Lauren
you know what you're using this I could
check it whenever I want but you know
what I don't want to
I don't want to be your police Dad yeah
I will if I have to but I don't want to
so hon just keep making good choices but
the fact that I could because I always
knew the passcode was enough of a
deterrent at that level based on a
little bit of checking that I've done
that she is making fabulous choices
online leading with the relationship and
the trust in the agency as opposed to
saying to a five-year-old who has zero
executive control
hey yeah good choices you know yeah yes
I think that conversation about trust in
young kids is so important that often
gets overlooked because I think one of
the most
um prevalent ways that we can explain a
healthy relationship an open
relationship with kids and their parents
is when their parents trust them because
I I think about growing up how my
parents trusted me and my sister and we
never felt a need or desire to hide
anything from them we didn't even have
curfews and so there'd be a time maybe
when I was 17 and I would come home a
little bit late because I was out with
my boyfriend Andrew who's now my husband
and he's my mom would say Ellen it's a
little late it's 11 30 and I'm like oh
you're right okay I'm sorry Mom I'll
come home at you know 10 next time on
10th I'll be sure to be home by 10 or 10
30 next time that kind of conversation
instead of you are past 10 30 you're
grounded all the things what we've found
is that our friends who their parents
were much more like that very
controlling didn't trust their kid or
assumed that their kid was always doing
something wrong that's when they would
do something that they shouldn't do
because my parents don't trust me
anyways I might as well do it it's kind
of what we noticed you know that if
there was If the parents were hovering
or um just like not trusting in their
kids that's tense tended to be our
friends who would do the things that
they probably shouldn't have been doing
no you're right in other words it sounds
like your parents they treated you with
the Assumption of good instead of the
Assumption of naughty yes and that's
something I say to parents all the time
it's like
maybe you have a good kid
just maybe you do yes I think kids we
don't give a lot of credit sometimes but
having worked in junior high Ministry
for a lot of years I think kids can
smell the difference in our parent team
yeah they've got this little radar and
they pick up on it little ways in our
tone and the way we treat them they can
tell the difference between a parent who
treats them with a maybe you're a good
kid perspective versus I bet they're
screwing up they can smell the
difference a mile away yeah because I
think about um like young teenage boys
and how when they are addicted to porn
it's a lot of hiding a lot of secrecy a
lot of going around when the parents
aren't looking to go access the computer
to look at porn because they're addicted
um but in those families is their trust
is their open honest communication when
they feel that they can come to their
parents and tell them how they're
feeling and what's going on that that
feeling like you mentioned earlier yeah
so at first my initial reaction when you
said my kids have my passcode to all my
devices right like iPhone or iPad I'm
like wait but then they could totally
just go when they're when you're not
around to go look at it sure but when
you layer on top of it the open
communication the trust aspect that
combination makes complete sense and it
resonates with how I was raised and how
healthy that is
yeah and I still have controls right
like I said I still have filters on my
phone Ellen I want to show them that
even dad needs help with technology and
they don't know my full story yet but I
was exposed to pornography at a very
young age which led to an adult
compulsive use of pornography which
almost destroyed me and so I look
at how easy it was in my adult brain
with all of my adult tools to
rationalize a lot of really bad activity
and a bad behavior and go wow that's
what motivates me to protect them but it
also says to me you know it's a really
smart idea boys that Dad filters his
device too because we all it's easy to
go well porn's not my problem okay
whatever it is it could be gambling it
could be shopping it could be Candy
Crush I don't care what it is I mean
whatever it is eventually the algorithm
figures us out
and eventually there are things that we
probably spend more time than we should
doing and so it's constantly asking am I
modeling the healthiest relationship as
I can with this thing in front of my
kiddos to your point so
yes I like I feel like this can't be
reiterated enough that's open
communication aspect of talking to your
kids at an early age because it's really
easy to be like well I'm just going to
hide all the devices and then they can't
come across it but the thing is they're
eventually going to come across it and
you want them to be prepared this is
something you talk about on your
Instagram everybody should go follow
your Instagram it's very helpful and
insightful on how to talk to young kids
and that combination of open
communication and trust with your kids
is going to set you up for a healthy
relationship with devices and with your
kids that's right digital trust in other
words we can't be a horrible parent in
the real world and expect our kids to
make great digital choices you know what
I mean like yell at them yell at them
yell at them and treat them a certain
way and then put rules around their
technology and just expect them to do
those things right it's there's such an
integration between that real world
Digital World sort of
parenting style that you're right yep
that's it's really huge so I'm glad you
brought that up and it's a awesome your
parents did that with you that's a great
model that you have to then be able to
show that to your children I'm going to
guess a lot of people who are listening
to this or watch this maybe didn't have
that model and are recovering
um we'll just say you know rebellious
teams because maybe they fought back
against some of those type parameters
and
it's a not it's it's
a battle that you will never win
especially in the digital age if you try
to go Toe to Toe with your kids on their
device you'll lose every time
right you'll just create a bunch of
digital ninjas that find a way around
anything
therefore we have to engage with the
relationship because they're starting at
a position more intelligent than we are
on the thing that we're trying to
control
right right so pivoting here can you
explain what sexortion is and the
difference between childhood when we
grew up versus childhood now
yeah especially right now so
um sextortion is a transaction that
looks and um it kind of goes like this
so imagine I'm a a child who has a phone
of some kind or an app of some kind and
I receive a message from somebody and
they promise me something and in
exchange they want something
compromising from me typically a nude
photo of some kind okay
and so I send that photo thinking I'm
going to get something back and it turns
out then that that is an adult who is
now going to extort me but sex extortion
right extort me for more or now what
it's turned to it used to be that this
was an exchange for give me more nude
photos right so it's more often young
ladies who are the victims of this who
would then be sick started and to send
me more of your nudes or I will leak
this to all of your family because I
have your passwords and they would make
all these threats and coerce them now
because I just sat through a
presentation
two weeks ago Ellen with the national
Center for missing and exploited
children so Nick MC the national I'd
call the global Clearing House for
online sexual abuse
is Nick MC right here in the United
States
and now 93 of cases are boys because
it's pivoted to financial sextortion
meaning they don't want more nude photos
they want you to go get your parents
credit card and they want or they want
you to send them some gift card or go to
the
um with your parents credit card go to
the local CVS and buy five 100 dollar am
you know Visa gift cards or something or
whatever it might be it's all about the
money and why are kids falling for
sending pictures of them themselves and
their bodies to people strangers online
well it goes back to something that we
talked about previously and that is kids
are sensitive to rewards if I'm a young
man and I think that there is some
beautiful woman or girl on the other
side of a conversation who has promised
me a nude photo of hers if I send a nude
photo from me that dopamine reward
system compels even really smart good
kids to make irrational decisions
and that's most of what happens it
happened right here in Michigan just
last year there was a senior in high
school an amazing young man football
player homecoming King and one night
he got coerced into sending a photo and
they threatened in this small community
to send this photo to other members of
his family others in the community and
the thought of that was so devastating
to him based on who he was and his
personality that he killed himself that
night wow that's crazy it's it's hard
and
and so that thought that my whole family
is going to find out and the pressure
Ellen is like ridiculous what they do
they will pound them with message after
message I'm going to tell I'm going to
tell I've got all this stuff and they we
have a lot of information about us out
there so it's really easy for a horrible
person to find out just enough about a
kid to make them think that they know
where they live or they know where they
go to school and they know who their
principal is or they know whoever to be
able to share something about them and
that is a devastating thought to a child
they would rather die than be
embarrassed and so that's what so the
the statistics the the FBI just put out
this week the uh alarm on this the
statistics are just off of the charts
right now so especially when kids are
home more you know I want parents to
have whether it's over break or other
times summer breaks you know Christmas
breaks other times I want us to have
these ridiculously direct and authentic
conversations with our kiddos to say
listen somebody might send you a photo
and they may sound like they're hot but
they're not
they are not who you think they are and
I don't care what every hormone in your
body is telling you to do
not send that photo here's the story of
a young man in Michigan who did this
there's 12 stories from all the U.S
these choices that have been made and
Ellen without getting into a lot of
detail some of the evil that is driving
some of this behavior is unfathomable
that in almost gang-like hierarchy there
is a reward if you convince a child to
kill him or herself like it's it's a
level of evil that is hard to Fathom on
the other side of that conversation they
do not care if the child takes his or
her life they don't care
but I want to I want to impress upon the
listeners that just based on the data
that we have for the last seven months
93 of those that are taken advantage of
in these sex extortion schemes are boys
so this is like gaming likely like do
you think it's likely in gaming and
video games or is it social media 51 of
the cases are Instagram 31 of the cases
are Snapchat and then 18 are a
combination of other apps hmm okay so
because gay other apps that could mean
I'm so bad at like um no it could be it
could be games to have chat features in
them right it could be yeah fortnite it
could be online games through the Xbox
or Playstation sure there's a whole
combination or Whatsapp you know a lot
of kids uh most humans outside of the
United States WhatsApp is the most
popular messaging app used right and so
that's a large one in that 18 percent
and so on your website do you have
um specifics on how to turn off ability
for conversing with strangers on gaming
as well even on your website okay cool
yeah that's something I think a lot of
people aren't thinking about because we
haven't even talked about
um the addiction that comes with video
games let alone social media but yeah
podcast time yeah I know I know wow that
is really this is all really incredible
information I think so many of us just
don't know at all the dangers that could
happen with young kids getting on social
media or having their smartphones too
young so I'm really thankful for
everything that you shared and before we
round it out could you just explain
um what policies you've worked for to
help protect children
sure so we work at both well I would say
at three levels I'm a big fan of walking
alongside schools who want to make
changes during the school day around how
technology is used because technology
does have a good and amazing place in
education and I want to help schools
find that so we work with hundreds of
schools all over the country to in a lot
of ways including that at the state
level we've worked on actively working
on legislation that defaults to safety
meaning if devices are activated in
certain States based on it detecting
let's say that a device was activated in
the state of Hawaii or Michigan or
wherever that it would set certain
filters by default now if you're an
adult you don't want them just uncheck
the box but wouldn't it be great if we
lived in a world like all of the
products that we buy that come in the
box or come in the mail safe what if our
devices were by default safe we actually
had to hunt for exploitation like that's
posture so we we've passed that
legislation in Utah I have other states
that we're working on and doing that at
the federal level which is obviously a
much more difficult place because of by
you know there's a lot of partisanism
and other things but I testified at the
U.S Senate back in 2019 the Senate
Judiciary Committee and there are a
number of different bills
it's this is obviously a point in time
where we're having this conversation and
people may listen to it months from now
but at this point in time there are a
couple of bills Cosa the kids online
safety act and others that are trying to
move the age to an older age than age 13
to when children can be targeted by
Media or targeted by marketing right to
collect it's privacy right we live in a
world right now in 2022 where we've
decided back in 1999
that age 13 was the age of digital
adulthood well 20 23 years later that is
no longer the right spot for digital
adulthood and so at the federal level
we're trying to do things like that to
get that age moved so that all apps
would have to treat children with a
certain level of privacy and respect
awesome well that is so great I'm so
thankful for everything you're doing to
help protect kids and help parents know
how to navigate these conversations with
their children I love your honest and
open uh policy and I think it's helping
so many people so definitely go follow
Chris on Instagram protect young eyes
and check out your website is just
protectyoung eyes.com right that's right
yes thank you great well thank you so
much for being here and I really
appreciate this conversation my pleasure
Ellen take care all right all right bye
everybody thanks for being here
foreign
[Music]